fa caldo
[Musica]
salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
era da un mese che non lo dicevo è vero
era da un po che non facevo una nuova
recensione ma ho voluto fargli una
sorpresa
ho voluto recensire non uno ma due film
che secondo me sono all'apice della
cinematografia italiana è giusto sono
due so bad it's good
i film che voglio recensire sono grazie
padre pio
un film diretto da amedeo gianfrotta del
2001 e 4 caronia malopasso un film del
1989 diretto dal grandissimo vito
colomba i cinque punti che vorrei usare
per descrivervi questi film sono cinque
punti in comune tra tutti e due
trama regia musiche e suoni azione e
recitazione quindi senza indugiare oltre
vediamo insieme quali sono i cinque
punti per cui questi due film dovrebbero
essere visti ed amati da tutti
numero 5 trama la trama di grazie padre
pio è imbarazzante
premetto che i due attori principali del
film sono gigione e jo donatello due
famosi credo cantanti napoletani
detto questo nel film gigione va in
tournée mentre il gioco donatello è
costretto a rimanere a casa incontra un
suo amico che gli propone di fare delle
gare clandestine solo che lui non sa che
queste gare sono gestite da don franco
un camorrista della zona
quindi lui si ficca nei casini gigione
torna scopre che jo donatello e nei
casini allora tenta di tirarlo fuori per
rimetterla sulla sua situazione a posto
sì in teoria in realtà è soltanto uno
squallidissimo pretesto per far
ascoltare le loro canzoni ma delle
canzoni parliamo dopo in 4 caroline
malopasso invece il grande gli immenso
l'inimitabile vito colomba di age un
western sapete già chi e non sono un
grande amatore di film western ma se
fossero stati fatti tutti così la mia
collezione avrebbe solo quelle la trama
racconta di billy nelson un uomo che
torna a casa propria dopo tanti anni e
scopre che i genitori sono stati uccisi
e quindi intraprenderà un viaggio per
cercare di vendicarli se in teoria in
pratica invece grazie al finale capisci
che tutto quello che è successo prima è
completamente inutile quindi come se tu
spettatore avessi visto il nulla
ho una voglia può più esasperante di di
spoiler harvey finale ma purtroppo voi
vi siete lamentati che spesso spoiler e
finali dei film che voi e poi andreste a
vedervi quindi questa volta non dico
niente purtroppo mi mangio le dita
numero 4 regia ringrazio padre pio il
regista gianfrotta riesce a far morire i
colori fa morire i colori che cavolo
vuol dire guardate colori sono morti
insieme al direttore della fotografia a
quanto pare c'è ma neanche in un film
della seconda guerra mondiale più cupo
più crudo ci sono questi colori così
spenti e lui si fa vedere questi
paesaggi più volte bastico si mette una
tristezza interiore immane è come
guardare un muro bianco su cui uno ci ha
buttato una secchiata di cemento
poi il resto dell'inquadratura e per
fortuna è molto molto molto basilare in
modo che si riesca a far capire più o
meno cosa sta succedendo vita colomba
con quattro caronia mano passo invece
gira delle inquadrature talmente lunghe
ma talmente lunghi che ogni tanto penso
che si sia addormentato con la macchina
da presa in mano ma sta succedendo
qualcosa o persino in scena in cui il
protagonista billy nelson va in giro per
le praterie con il cavallo
io mi immagino sempre una roba tipo red
dead redemption che anche se può
risultare un po noiosa andare per ore
con il cavallo almeno in parte non ci
sono molto molto belli no
[Musica]
un piattume generale impressionante un
po di tempo fa io sono dovuto andare a
fare una visita medica e sono rimasto
nella sala d'attesa per oltre un'ora e
mezza con il cellulare scarico e non
sapevo cosa fare ma mi sono divertito
molto di più a fare quello che sa
guardare queste scene che non finiscono
mai
numero 3 musiche e suoni partiamo da
grazie padre pio
mi tolgo le cose facili subito va così è
meglio durando soltanto 40 minuti grazie
padre pio
tu lo guardi sperando che finisca il più
in fretta possibile
o che ti arrivi un infarto ma non arriva
mai e tutti guardi i dialoghi utenti di
seguire la trama quando ad un certo
punto succede questo
[Musica]
non cantano io odio quando nei film
cantano non perché non mi piaccia la
musica io adoro la musica
ogni volta che in un film cantano sembra
quasi che sprechino tempo ma almeno nei
musical e nei film della disney le
canzoni sono belle queste
[Musica]
quanto ti amo
no sempre
per l'amor del cielo non potrebbero
essere più banali di così
mi viene da vomitare arcobaleni e io non
voglio criticare gigione e jo donatello
come cantante anche perché non le avevo
mai sentito in vita mia e non posso
criticare una persona che non ho mai
sentito cantare in vita mia ma vorrei
chiedervi una cosa voi amanti di gigione
e jo donatello
tutte le canzoni loro sono così e se sì
come fate essere ancora vivi io ho visto
persone suicidarsi per molto molto meno
ma passiamo a 4 carogne una delle cose
che si nota subito in quattro carogna ma
lo basso è l'audio dei dialoghi e cap a
tenere oggi ci sono ancora ma che cazzo
sta dice io non sento nulla io dicevo
che almeno l'ottanta per cento di quello
che si dice però io non lo capivo poi se
contiamo che ogni frase veniva detta
dopo mezz'ora di scena vuota
completamente inutili dove quello andava
a cavallo e tu aspetti questa frase con
trepidazione perché finalmente c'è un
dialogo e non capisci quello che succede
quello che quello che cavolo si stanno
dicendo
potete immaginare come tutto il film e
questo a differenza di grazie padre pio
duro un'ora e mezza e poi arriva la
colonna sonora e adesso immaginatevi le
grandi musiche le grandi colonne sonore
che ennio morricone creava per i film di
sergio leone il grande suono il grande
ritmo che riusciva a ricreare per le
scene d'azione per le scene di viaggio
per le scene nei saloon cui è
leggermente diverso
[Musica]
leggermente diverse ogni volta che io
sentivo quella musica assordante lì ma
non mi veniva in mente un western o o
comunque una colonna sonora esistente
[Musica]
ha sentito questo tipo di musica quindi
capisci che i dialoghi non sono quel
così un problema
12 azione ed ecco che iniziamo ad
avvicinarci ai pezzi forti dei film che
voi ci credete no in un film chiamato
grazie padre pio ci sono delle scene
d'azione come ho detto prima gio
donatello si invischia nel giro delle
gare clandestine
le gare sono molto pericolose potrebbero
far morire anche il pilota più bravo
soprattutto se vai a 20 chilometri orari
ma che razza di gara clandestina e ma
dai che tra l'altro lui gareggia per
tipo un mese ma ne fanno vedere giusto 2
guarda che roba l'adrenalina a mille in
quattro carogna malopasso invece ci sono
le sparatorie ovviamente che devo dire
mi aspettavo molto peggio
[Musica]
cioè fanno schifo appunto ma mi
aspettavo molto peggio ma a quanto pare
il regista detto le sparatorie sono
venute un po un biglietto troppo bene
dobbiamo mettere qualcosa che smentì
tutto e così ha messo una scena di lotta
a mani nude
prego
[Musica]
da dove iniziò a parte il fatto che più
finta di così gli attori non potevano
farla è vero che non hanno usato
controfigure però porca miseria possiamo
sentire soprattutto all'inizio della
lotta che l'audio non riprenda
assolutamente quello che sta succedendo
[Musica]
sono chiaramente suoni di una lotta che
non è la loro
sarà preso probabilmente da qualche
altro film non lo so è una tristezza
numero 1 recitazione ditelo che ve lo
aspettavate dai dai di tela qui ho
pensato e ripensato a cosa dire per
commentare le scene che sto per farvi
vedere ma alla fine parlano da sole non
so se avete capito la battuta scene di
recitazione parlano da sole scene di
recitazione che parlano non avete capito
no e fatela voi la battuta comunque
partiamo dalle scene migliori di grazie
padre pio non ti è piaciuta la canzone
no anzi mi è piaciuta tantissimo perché
se triste è che penso a tutta quella
gente che soffre combatte
quotidianamente per la libertà già
questo rattrista anche a me ma adesso
basta via la tristezza non stavi forse
per baciarmi
[Musica]
lo sai
sei un uomo che fa eccezione sarebbe sai
fare bene tutto sai correre sai cantare
fai fare bene l'amore solo non solo le
scene di eccitazione più belle che
abbiate mai visto in vita vostra cece
belle tra virgolette manera sottointeso
e adesso le mie preferite in assoluto di
quattro caronia malopasso qui billy
nelson scopre che i suoi genitori sono
stati assassinati
ma perche meneghetto questo sceriffo
quanti colpi billy i tuoi sono stati
assassinati anni fa no no a scaldare ve
la faccio a rivedere soprattutto per
farvela gustare ancora un po ma perche
mele ghezzano questo che i phone i pad i
corpi billy i tuoi sono stati
assassinati anni ma no no e poi
ovviamente inizia a non capirci più
nulla ed è un casino
comunque questi erano grazie padre pio e
4 caronia malopasso 23 migliori film
trash italiani ma infatti nella storia e
il bello è che potete trovarli su
youtube e da nessun altra parte anche
perché credo che le abbiano dati in tv
una volta in tutta la vita quindi però
prima di concludere volevo dirvi un mio
pensiero mio parere che so che potrà
cadere nel banale ma vabbe per quanto
siano fatti male per quanti siano
putridi orribilmente recitati era ancora
peggio girati farà anche rivas è quasi
una filastrocca
mi piacciono sono belli sono solo film
che ti lasciano qualcosa
a differenza di tutti quei film che
escono al cinema negli ulti italiani
ovviamente negli ultimi periodi anche in
tv sono film fatti bene recitati bene
con una trama scritta come si deve ma
c'è una particolarità per me questi film
sono inutili sono completamente inutili
perché non ti lasciano nulla
tu li guardi a noi riuscì dopo che ne
sono finiti cece caruccio fine gli altri
film sono inutili questi almeno te li
ricorderò per tutta la vita sono finché
non ti dimenticherà mai
e poi ti fai tante di quelle risate in
compagnia che son fantasies è un film
veramente fantastici
ovviamente non li giustifico per quanto
siano brutti però devo dire che sono
belli da vedere a differenza di quelli
lì ma questo è il mio pensiero
ripeto è molto banale è facile dire i
film di adesso fanno schifo so meglio
meglio quelli vecchi
ma questi sono soli dei libri di un
pazzo che fa video su youtube
io vi saluto mi scuso ancora per il
ritardo ma volevo assolutamente farvi
conoscere queste queste due perle del
cinema italiano incrociando le dita che
un giorno ne uscirà ancora un altro
franco columbu e ivano de cristofaro nel
film dell'anno
dreamland la terra dei sogni al cinema
[Musica]
oddio